Back in 1482,
a young man heard that the region of Milan
was looking for an engineer,
so he did what job applicants do.
He wrote down his skills
and his objectives
and how they related to the role
in what is thought to be
the first resume ever created.
That young man was Leonardo da Vinci.
You see, Da Vinci, in his resume,
never put anything down
about his past achievements.
For context, Da Vinci was one
of the most talented people
to ever walk on the face
of the planet, right?
He was the father of architecture
and palaeontology,
an expert botanist,
astronomer and cartographer.
The guy that painted the Mona Lisa.
Yet if you took a look at his resume,
you would never guess that he was capable
of achieving any of those things.
If resumes failed to capture
the genius and the potential
of someone like Da Vinci,
why do we think that it'll
work for you and me?
Why will they work for anyone?
Centuries later,
why do resumes play such an important part
in recruiting and our careers
despite little to no evidence
that they actually work?
In fact, since the 1950s,
they've become a mainstay
in the job application process.
And although we have since
put a man on the moon,
cracked the human genome,
created a metaverse
and somehow kept up
with all of the Kardashians,
the biggest --
(Laughter)
the biggest innovation
when it comes to resumes
has been converting it from paper to PDF.
Why are we not questioning this?
Where we have seen innovation
is with applicant tracking systems,
bots, AI that scan thousands
and thousands of resumes
looking for keywords
that match the job description.
These bots are used by nearly
all Fortune 500 companies,
so although most of the time
you're preparing your resume
for it to be reviewed
by another human being,
they often get rejected by AI
before it even reaches a person.
If this is all news to you
and you're looking for a job,
then you’re playing the job search game,
and you don’t know the rules.
Hardly anyone does.
And the problem there
is that AI still has a long way to go,
and machine learning is nowhere near
to making predictions
on candidates’ success.
I've been working in HR now
for more than a decade.
During this time, I've reviewed
thousands of resumes
and made many countless hiring decisions.
Which, by default, makes me
the resume doctor
for everyone that knows me.
You see, whenever a friend,
a friend's friend, their husband,
their wives, their kids, their friends
are looking for a job,
I'm the first person they call
when they need help with their resume.
Irrespective of where
they are in their careers,
there's all this insecurity and anxiety
when it comes to their resume.
Why do people get so nervous
about something so silly
as updating a resume?
We've all been there,
up late at night, trying to apply
for that dream role,
obsessing over each
bullet point and detail.
As if, if we spend 20 more
minutes on the resume,
it'll somehow be perfect.
It will become the ideal resume.
As if the ideal resume exists.
It doesn't, it's very subjective.
And because of that,
there's so much conflicting information.
Depending on who you ask,
resume should only be one page long.
Others say two pages long.
Others suggests a summary or objectives.
Others say try and make it
visually pleasing.
You can't have too much white space,
but if you have too much text,
it just looks too busy.
And then there's all these articles online
that deep dive into the minutia
all the way to the absurd
when it comes to resumes,
arguing about things like font psychology
and how using a sexy font
like Arial or Calibri --
(Laughter)
will better serve you in your job search
versus a boring one like Times New Roman.
(Laughter)
Who would have thought
that that would have any correlation
with how good you could do the job?
And the absurdity continues.
Hobbies and interests.
Do you include them,
or do you leave them out?
If you leave them out,
does it make your resume
look too impersonal?
If you leave them in,
what if your hobbies are weird?
(Laughter)
What if you enjoy dressing up
like Pokemon characters
or collecting Beanie Babies?
Will that cost you a job?
During the entire time,
as you're spiraling down this rabbit hole,
you're not questioning the tool
or the process itself.
You're questioning yourself.
Is it me? Am I the problem?
The answer is no.
Resumes are a terrible metric
for assessing who you are at work,
and the world of work
is constantly evolving.
There was a time,
10 years into your career,
you had two to three jobs at most.
Now it's common for people
to change jobs once every year
and have multiple side hustles, too.
Those student loans are not going
to pay for themselves, right?
A resume doesn't do you justice
if you have a non-traditional path.
And a non-traditional path
is now the norm.
Although corporate America
has made a ton of progress
in the way of equity and inclusion,
relying on resumes is a magnet
for discriminatory practices
and unconscious bias.
More specifically,
when Black and Asian candidates
whiten their names,
they're more successful
in their job search.
The same applies to when women
change their name to a man's.
But men were not immune to this either,
and we often get rejected for roles
in female-dominated fields.
The pressure to fit your experience
on one piece of paper
for experienced candidates
can be too much.
And studies have shown
that candidates as young as their 30s
face ageism with resume sourcing.
So you can imagine
what the experience is like
for someone coming out of retirement.
Don't believe me?
Try applying for an entry-level role
with an AOL.com email account.
(Laughter)
The great resignation has forced employers
to revisit how they evaluate,
treat and reward their employees,
but also how they attract new ones.
But they're having candidates go
through the same stupid process
expecting different results.
As in, "Here's the job description,
send us your resume,
let's take six to seven
seconds to review it,"
rinse and repeat.
And then they wonder why
they're not getting enough candidates.
So let's rethink one of the most
redundant benchmarks
for entry into any type of role.
Summarizing a lifetime of achievements
isn't just hard for someone like Da Vinci.
It's hard for everyone else.
During a time where we celebrate
authenticity and creativity,
why are we asking for something
so conformative and, frankly, boring?
We can do better.
Resumes not only force you to lie
about your experience,
they force you to use
all these silly buzzwords
that you would never use
in the context of a real conversation.
Like "orchestrated" or "spearheaded."
People don't talk like that.
Who are you, Dr. Evil?
(Laughter)
Yet if you're honest,
you're just increasing your chances
of getting rejected.
So what can we ask
as an alternative to a resume?
Well, we can conduct
online skills assessments
or request portfolios of work,
like they already do
in certain industries.
We can ask for a video testimonial
so we can assess one
of the most important skills
in any type of role -- communication.
We can leverage technology
to have candidates team with each other
to solve a problem so we can assess
how they work with other people.
We can put candidates through simulations
or situational assessments
like an in tray exercise so we can see
how they act in a specific scenario.
Even better, we can gamify the entire
process to engage candidates.
This could be an online quiz
or a challenge
that would motivate
goal-driven professionals.
Heck, we can even invite candidates
to our offices to solve a problem
and then purposefully
slow down their internet,
just so we can see
how they react under pressure.
But joking aside, the list goes on and on.
Better leveraging technology,
being more creative
and having different options
for people to apply
will not only produce
a better talent pool,
it will also create a much
more equitable workplace.
And I know a lot of people
won't agree with me.
They'll say mixing things up
costs time and money,
but hiring the wrong person
has a higher price.
Almost 30 percent of their annual salary
plus all the time it took
for you to train them.
Subsequently,
it's all about building trust
and a culture of belonging.
If you ask any CEO about their culture,
they'll say it's unique.
But to apply to be a part of it
is exactly the same as their competitors,
which not only limits their options,
they end up competing
for the same type of talent
which results in workplaces
that lack diversity.
If your culture is inclusive,
have people choose how they want to apply
so they can customize their experience
and put their best foot forward.
Ultimately, there are better
alternatives than the resume,
and maybe we don't need
to get rid of them completely.
But do we need to obsessively rely on them
just for the sake of what we're used to?
You don't need to be as talented or gifted
or even have as much free time
on your hands as Da Vinci
to learn from him that you don't need
to be defined by your resume.
And once employers realize this,
then we'll begin creating workplaces
that feel welcoming to candidates
even before they join.
Plus, it will give us enough time
to rethink cover letters,
because those are really terrible.
Thank you.
(Applause)